[Music]
kabali National Park is in western
Uganda
and it was a forest preserved for quite
a while before it became a national park
was actually established as a forest
reserve in 1932 by the British colonial
authorities in 1995 if it officially
became a national park chimpanzees are
interesting as chimpanzees but they do
have a privileged position when it comes
to looking at humans and trying to
understand the origins of ourselves and
of our own behavior over the years I've
done focused research on aspects of
social relationships especially those of
males which are really interesting and
important in chimpanzees males are
fascinating they are really unusual for
mammals and in ways that are rather like
male humans males are more sociable than
females and they spend just more time
with other adult chimpanzees and
especially with each other and they they
are rivals they compete they compete for
mating opportunities they just they
compete for status which then can
influence mating opportunities but
there's a lot of friendly interaction
that goes on between males and male
chimpanzees groom with each other more
than they groom with females and more
than females groom with each other and
that's the exact opposite of what you
would see in a baboon group for example
males also cooperate with each other in
other ways they form some of them form
alliances with each other they will back
each other up against others in their
community and that can be extremely
important in males efforts to rise in
rank and the dominance hierarchy and
especially can be really important for a
male who becomes alpha he may not get
there unless he has effective alliances
and if he gets there he may not be able
to quite likely won't be a
stay there and whisk in unless he has
some allies who will back him up against
other males on another level though all
the males in a community are allies with
each other against males in neighboring
communities and again one of the
somewhat disturbingly human-like aspects
of chimpanzee behavior is that
neighboring groups don't get along in
fact they are intensely hostile to each
other and most of the hostility is males
against outsiders and it takes the form
of groups of males in engaging in
aggression towards outsiders and if they
meet a group of outsiders and they're
sort of evenly matched then they may
make a lot of noise but they're unlikely
to try to get engaged in any serious
fights if it's 15 from n go go and only
one or only a few from the neighboring
community then they try to attack them
and then it's all the males from in Go
Go cooperating in this and making a gang
attack really that can be extremely
serious to the point where they kill
other chimpanzees a number of Yale
graduate students who have done PhD work
there and some of them have also
incorporated laboratory work into their
project so they go there and do
fieldwork and they go around following
chimpanzees and collect urine from them
for example and then they can do
hormonal asses back here and you can get
information on endocrinology you can get
genetics data and then that allows us to
really to answer questions that people
have wanted to have answers to but not
been able to but if we can get enough
good data on genetics then we can tell
who the fathers are which you could
never do from behavioural data given the
chimpanzee mating system which is
complicated but most of the mating that
is most of the copulations between males
and females take place in situations
where there's a female who's interested
in may
and she's with a number of males
sometimes especially in gogo
many sexually mature males and she may
actually mate with all of them we just
can't know who the fathers are unless we
can do paternity determinations using
DNA which is possible now and we have
well over 70 paternity determinations
that's an extraordinary number to have
that many now and this is an ongoing
project now we know who a lot of the
fathers are we can see if there's
anything unusual about relationships
between know that male and his actual
offspring compared to his relationship
say to other infants or juveniles
mothers and their offspring can have
really lifelong social ties with each
other although for the most part that's
mothers and their sons we have one
wonderful old lady who has to be in her
50s now and she has a son who himself is
getting rather old now he's definitely
middle-aged he's our best guess is he's
in his late 30s they still spend a lot
of time together they groom with each
other especially he grooms her a lot
he's he's a he's a good son he's still
very close with his mother there's a lot
of variation in the social worlds of
females and at an gogo one important
finding we've made is that the females
there are more sociable than females in
most other chimpanzee populations and
that's because they've got a better food
supply generally and given that better
availability of food they can just
afford to be with each other more and
some of them have long-term social bonds
with each other and in a few cases we've
discovered or we know that these are
mothers and daughters and the daughters
have not emigrated but in other cases we
know they aren't related to each other
but they've developed real friendships
with each other and these clearly can
last for years and years
chimpanzees are omnivores and they they
mostly eat fruit and the leaves and
plant stems and flowers and in some
places but not really didn't go go they
some insects they like to eat meat and
they eat more meat than any other
primates except humans and they get it
by hunting and usually hunts involve
groups of chimpanzees who go after
groups of monkeys and wherever
chimpanzees live with red colobus
monkeys they focus on them and they
especially hunt them they don't eat meat
every day they might go for weeks
without any and some individuals go for
longer than that but they really like it
and it makes sense it's not easy to get
but it's nutritionally complete food
essentially it's it's very valuable
nutritionally even small bits of it
could be valuable to them so first of
all they get wildly excited while they
are hunting and then when they have meat
and someone has some others are really
excited then they want some and they
share me I often see things like one
male has a monkey and he will bite off a
leg and literally hand it to someone
else who's likely to be his know his
ally or his number-one grooming partner
this is again it's highly unusual
behavior compared to other mammals but
rather like what humans do um the just
the willingness to share and the extent
to which everyone can benefit when they
have something valuable like this a
couple of years ago one of my students
from Yale and I were out one day and we
found a big group of chimpanzees a big
party as we call them um out in the
western part of the in gogo chimps
territory and there was a lot of
excitement when we got there many
chimpanzees together lots of good food
um and we thought oh where this is going
to be a good day we're gonna see a lot
of interesting things but then we
realized that really there was a lot of
excitement
down the hill from where we were in this
little valley we got down there and we
found that the chimpanzees had
encountered alliance snares that
poachers had set Quentin who was then a
young an adolescent female who had
pretty recently joined the in Go Go
community had been caught in a snare
she'd managed to break away from the
pole but she had this length of she had
a the noose of wire pulled very tightly
around her hand and she had which and
she was trailing this wire and it had
gotten caught up in some vegetation and
she was desperately trying to free
herself but she was she didn't know how
to do that so she was pulling and
pulling and just making things worse and
and the other chimpanzees were very
upset by this and several came right up
to her even touch her and gently
reassuringly they didn't know how to get
her free so I think they were showing a
kind of a real concern
[Music]
we pay several men who are experts at
anti-poaching work and they work with
Park Rangers they help train them they
also work on their own sometimes and
they do a great job and they really
contribute importantly to protection of
the chimpanzees and their habitat but
they can only cover a small fraction of
that habitat and they could find more
men whom they could train who would also
do a good job and the Ugandan Park
authorities have told us that they would
be happy to have us hire more men to
cover more of the park and the only
question is at the moment we don't have
the money to do that if we did then we
could really step up the protection of
the chimpanzees well there's a world out
there that's somewhat parallel tum' to
mine as a an academic and a researcher
and that's the world of people who make
wildlife documentaries alistair
Fothergill who was the producer for the
chimpanzee film the disney nature film
he was the one who really came up with
the idea of doing a feature film and he
also approached John Mitani my colleague
collaborator and me and said this was
what he was trying to do he wanted to
make this film would we be amenable to
working with him and having the film
crew come to a go-go and so on this is
not a documentary unlike the BBC films
but it is just chimpanzees and it's all
footage of wild chimpanzees and he
wanted to have a film crew come to a
go-go because he knew that that's the
place to film wild chimpanzees I had two
roles in the film process and one was
that they asked me to look at scripts
and if I said oh well you know this
makes no sense whatsoever this would
never happen
um they were willing to listen
that and change it a bit usually what I
did was I went out early while they were
getting ready getting their equipment
packed up and so on and I had a radio so
I could call to them back in camp and
say you know I'm out it you know each
10:00 and I've got a good group here so
you should head out this way then I
would help follow the chimps help them
keep up with them during the day the
cameraman bill wall hour who is an
expert wildlife cinematographer also
knows chimpanzees because he worked for
the Jane Goodall Institute at Gombe for
many years I could certainly give him a
lot of background information about oh
this is miles he's the alpha male now
and this is his history and this is
what's going on between him and monk
who's over there and who's sort of his
ally now they understood that it's
really important to have that context to
know what to look for and try to film in
the first place and then to make sense
out of the images that they got when
they know the context and in know the
history and they know even who they're
looking at and what those individuals
are like and what their relationships
with each other are it will have a lot
of good information about chimpanzees
and it will that will go along with just
amazing images wonderful photography and
I hope it inspires even more people to
understand that these are very
complicated animals and they are
fascinating and wonderful and also that
their their status is rather shaky now
they're in trouble in the wild and they
need attention and they need help from
people it is overwhelmingly clear now
that the presence of long term research
projects helps to protect habitats and
helps to protect the animals we did
stand to learn a lot about ourselves and
about human evolutionary history
certainly by looking at chimpanzees
and there are some obvious places to
look and just at hunting and meat
sharing for example or a male aggression
towards outsiders these are things that
are characteristics of humans
[Music]
you